je vous laisse avancer la gagnante
[Musique]
la Star Academy
Annie
avec ses doutes ses rêves sa fragilité
et sa puissance se voit remettre
aujourd'hui le trophée de la victoire
l'audio final était donc composé d'inola
et Anisha qui ont tout donné jusqu'au
bout quand même chanter ensemble
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es
[Musique]
où tu as
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la star de la soirée c'était le
parrain de cette saison Robbie Williams
qui restait fidèle à lui-même dès son
arrivée
[Applaudissements]
le monde de la
[Musique]
bonsoir mon ami salut
de nous faire l'honneur d'être le
parrain de notre élève vous avez suivi
la saison
yes
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore
il était avec des meufs
c'est quoi tu crois vraiment que Robbie
Williams tous les Samed on sort ou pas
tu es fou ou quoi je dois regarder la
stars il est venu mais il est incroyable
j'adore
oui ça lui va bien et lui surtout il est
extrêmement darka j'adore alors
évidemment il était pas là pour montrer
son joli Hulk il a chanté avec les deux
finalistes et Lola et Annie chat
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors l'une des invités de cette finale
c'est Nolwenn Leroy et apparemment elle
était venu pour chanter et Nolwenn c'est
vrai que j'aime beaucoup elle a elle pas
elle adore s'exprimer Nolwenn elle kiffe
elle adore se faire des amis et regardez
Nolwenn c'était en fait elle voulait
elle avait envie de parler
j'étais ici et
je savais que je serais mieux mais il y
a une grosse charge émotionnelle quand
même d'être parmi vous ce soir et de
c'est une grande interprète et j'ai
adoré Noël là je vous ai tous adoré bien
sûr et je sais qu'on aura certainement
l'occasion de chanter ensemble dans le
futur
et je voudrais aussi dire un grand merci
à tous les professeurs parce que cette
année
merci beaucoup
accompagné Nolwenn s'il vous plaît merci
[Applaudissements]
Nolwenn il devrait lui faire annuler un
truc Nolwenn il devrait lui faire un
truc je trouve qu'elle a un truc elle a
un truc elle est très sympathique et on
voit qu'elle aime ça alors apparemment
certaines prestations étaient
enregistrées le samedi après-midi pour
des questions de logistique sauf que
c'était pas du tout discret et à moins
Kerin Eric Antoine était en coulisse
Anissa elle s'est séchée à la fin
nouveau brushing en 2 minutes chrono ça
ça n'est jamais arrivé à la télévision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas toujours la plus belle
[Musique]
c'est pas mal ça
franchement c'est fort et lors de la
finale il y avait Yanis le look son look
a fait débat sur les réseaux beaucoup le
juger trop posé trop sexy le chorégraphe
à nous créer un petit un petit moment de
voilà de solitude quand il a parlé avec
Nikos c'est ce qu'on dit les réseaux
sociaux moi j'ai pas vu donc je vais le
découvrir avec vous puisque comme Robbie
Williams samedi soir c'est je regarde
pas trop la star incroyable vous avez
tellement de styles que tout passe avec
vous ne se voit pas le micro
attends là il y a trop de choses j'ai
trop d'accessoires qu'est-ce que tu vois
là je vois un bel homme
[Musique]
faut que je te fasse la Corée du cowboy
toujours tu as vu mon état je bouge
boîte parce que je me suis viandé il y a
trois semaines
il est darka moi je trouve ouais non moi
je trouve qu'il amène un truc je suis
désolé je préfère des mecs qui ont des
personnes qui a des personnalités
ça a été un vrai succès pardon même moi
mon avis j'ai beaucoup aimé il y a
quatre trucs qui m'a choqué c'est un
succès ça c'est un succès pas marché
de savoir c'est que cette semaine et
donc juste avant les votes il était sur
Sud Radio et donner une interview et on
lui a dit pour qui tu vas voter et il a
dit je vais voter pour Louis parce que
je soutiens ma communauté ça j'ai trouvé
ça extrêmement étonnant c'est à dire que
tout d'un coup on chantait tout pour un
chanteur mais parce qu'il est gay il
soutenait à gay parce que c'était black
non j'ai trouvé ça assez étonnant ce
qu'il est comme ça il y a ici
moi je suis d'accord
je suis désolé bien sûr il est ce qu'il
est vraiment gay
[Applaudissements]
faut pas mettre de communauté dans la
star c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
tu veux que je te dise c'est peut-être
maladroit ou ce que tu veux mais on
adore ça moi j'adore les mecs comme ça
tu veux que je te dise j'aime pas les
mecs moi qui voilà qui est langue de
bois au moins il dit voilà je suis un
autre mec non écoute-moi les quatre les
trois beaucoup de talents voilà
ouvre-moi
j'adore j'adore ce genre de personne
alors justement vous a fait une compil
des meilleures tenues du chorégraphe de
cette saison je sais pas où il s'habille
mais c'est fort Guillaume de savoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va pas du tout
nous
moi j'adore le talent et il a du talent
je suis désolé il a du talent à la
Chabat aussi il a du talent parce que on
dit ouais et lui il a du talent c'est
des mecs qui ont du talent je suis
désolé oui il a du talent il a
énormément de talents il crève l'écran
sans lui on se serait ennui à qui
d'autre après dans la vie génial
[Rires]
personne n'y croyait tout le monde
disait au début les profs ils sont nuls
je suis désolé c'est devenu des stars en
6 semaines les élèves pareil le casting
des Chambé on disait il y a pas de stars
ils ont pas eu besoin de ça franchement
c'est un succès et ça c'est une émission
qui marche sur TF1 et eux aussi ils
étaient après le foot ils ont cartonné
ils ont cartonné emménagère parce que
c'était bien et la clé de leur succès
parce qu'ils avaient quand même beaucoup
moins d'argent que les saisons
précédentes c'est le casting et toutes
les émissions comme ça qui marche
aujourd'hui à la télé comme l'amour est
dans le pré comme la Star Academy là ils
avaient un très bon casque internet
quand on avait ouais j'étais le premier
pas y croire ils nous ont bien fermé
notre gueule
on va revenir sur les meilleurs moments
de cette star ac a commencé par Nikos
qui était en roue libre complète pendant
les primes regardez les deux prochains
ils sont en côte à côte on m'a dit c'est
c'est elle est où là car là car là car
là pour tout vous dire je suis arrivé ce
matin de Los Angeles
[Applaudissements]
non non je plaisante
pas de top 3 ce soir il y a trois duos
non nommés donc forcément dans le top 3
on a fait un top 1 est-ce que vous
m'avez compris moi non plus parce que je
vous ai parlé de mon lumbago
[Applaudissements]
et cette année il y a plus d'un
candidats qui ont eu prendre quelques
cours de chant de en plus avant de se
présenter après c'est vrai qu'on dirait
c'est assez difficile et là-bas le son
c'est très dur hein sur un plateau comme
ça regardez
[Musique]
je vois les autres
rejetées sur moi c'est pas ma faute
avant
notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
et on démarre
[Musique]
alors on va revenir aussi la première je
l'adore la petite est venue là vendredi
je l'adore j'ai envie de la faire venir
dans les Tiana j'ai envie de la faire
venir dans l'émission même quand on vit
qu'elle fasse la grosse rigolade avec
nous Jean-Marie pour le 8 décembre je
l'adore elle est incroyable on avait
également les chéris naps que j'embrasse
était là pour le kiffe je l'adore et lui
aussi
il sait pas trop se mettre dans le prime
leur interprétation j'aime bien tu vois
ça
faut voter pour eux ok ok
[Musique]
qui qui remporteront
un des deux en tout cas ça peut pas être
les deux mais en tout cas que que vous
ayez une carrière une carrière parce que
il y en a qui ont pas gagné forcément la
star
donc il faut toujours être dans la
politique
allez on va finir avec cette extrait le
château de la Star qui s'est transformé
en maison de Sosie cette saison
et surtout on va finir par cette soldat
dans le château c'est Julien voilà qui a
fait un faux P voilà
c'est l'un d'arcade est-ce que vous
réalisez c'est incroyable
moi je suis fan de son timbre de voix je
trouve qu'il a atteindre exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis pas très stressé comme mec de
base voilà j'essaie justement de
déstresser les gens
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est important de se détendre le matin
[Applaudissements]
c'est sur un terrain venir l'antenne sur
TF1 puisque ça a été un succès donc ça
va revenir à l'antenne c'est sûr et
certain